let's say I've got a set of numbers
two-fifths got three threes I've got a
couple of fours and I've got a 10 there
and what we want to do is find the
middle of these numbers we want to
represent these numbers with the center
of the numbers or the middle of the
numbers just so we have a sense of where
these numbers are where they roughly are
and this central tendency that we're
going to try to get out of these numbers
we're going to call the average the
average of this set of numbers and you
I'm sure heard the Nate the word average
before but we're gonna get a little bit
more detailed on the different types of
averages in this video the one you're
probably most familiar with although you
might have not seen it referred to in
this way is the arithmetic mean
arithmetic mean which literally says
look I the arithmetic mean of this set
of numbers is literally the sum of all
of these numbers divided by the number
of numbers there are so the arithmetic
mean for this set right here is going to
be 2 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 4 plus 4
plus 10 all of that over how many
numbers do I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 all of
that over 7 and what is this equal to
this is 2 plus 9 which is 11 Plus 8
which is 19 plus 10 which is 29 so this
is going to be equal to 29 over 7 or you
could say it's equal to 4 and 1/7 if I
got my calculator out we could figure
out the decimal of this but this is a
representation of the central tendency
or the middle of these numbers and it
kind of makes sense
four and 1/7 it's a little bit higher
than 4 if we're kind of close to the
middle of our number range right there
and you might say well it's a little
skewed to the right and what caused that
in well Jesus 10 is a little bit larger
than all of the other numbers it's kind
of an outlier
maybe that's skewed this average up the
arithmetic mean
so there are other types of averages
although this is the one that if people
just say hey let's take the average of
these numbers and they don't really tell
you more they're probably talking about
the arithmetic mean the other forms of
average though are the median the median
and this literally is the middle number
the middle number and if there are two
middle numbers you actually take the
arithmetic mean of those two middle
numbers you actually find the number
halfway in between those two middle
numbers so the median of this set right
here let me just rewrite them so I have
a two three three three four four ten so
let's see we have seven numbers right
here the middle number if I go one two
three to the right we're there if we go
one two three to the left were there the
middle number is that three right there
I just listed them in order and I said
well like three is you could think of it
as the fourth number from the right and
it's also the fourth number from the
left three is the middle number in this
case it is the median so in this case
three if you use the median is our
average and that also makes sense I mean
it's literally the middle number and if
you look at this set of numbers it kind
of does represent the central tendency
of this set now just to be clear it was
very clear what the middle number was
because I had an odd number of numbers
it was you know I have three on each
side of the three so it was very easy to
figure out the median the middle number
but if I had a situation let's say I
have the situation where I have two
three four and five let's say that's my
set of numbers well here there is no one
middle number the three is closer to the
left than it is to the right the four is
closer to the right than it is to the
left there's actually two middle numbers
here the two middle numbers here are the
three and the four and here when you
have two middle numbers which occurs
when you have an even number in your
data set there the median is the halfway
in between
these two numbers so in this situation
the median is going to be 3 plus 4 over
2 which is equal to 3.5 and if you look
at this data set that's not what our
original problem was but if you look at
this data set right there you're
actually going to find that the
arithmetic mean and the median here is
the exact same thing let's let's
calculate it
what's the arithmetic mean over here
it's going to be 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus 5
which is what 5 plus 9 which is equal to
14 which is equal to 14 over 4 over 4
and what's this equal to 14 over 4 is 3
and 2 4 or 3 and a half the exact same
thing so for this data set they were the
same thing for this data set our median
is a little bit lower our median is a
little bit lower it's 3 while our
arithmetic mean is 4 and 1/7 and I
really want you to think about why that
is and it has a lot to do with this 10
that sits out there all of these other
numbers are pretty close to whichever
average you want to pick whether it's
the arithmetic mean or it's the median
but this 10 is kind of an outlier it's
kind of an outlier it's it skews the
data set maybe it you know it's it's so
much larger than the other numbers that
it makes the arithmetic mean seem larger
than maybe is representative of this
data set and that's something important
to think about when you're looking when
you're when you're finding the average
for something the the most people will
immediately go to the arithmetic mean
but in a lot of cases median will make a
lot more sense if you have these really
large or really small numbers that could
skew the data set I mean you could
imagine if this wasn't a 10 or let's
Adam imagine adding another number here
if I added the number 1 million if I
added 1 million to this data set if that
was the 8th number the arithmetic mean
is going to be this huge number it's
going to be it's going to be much larger
than what is representative of most of
the numbers in this data set but the
median is still going to work the median
is still going to be about 3 and a half
right if you had a million here it'd be
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 the middle two numbers
would be that it would be 3 and 1/2 so
the median is less sensitive to one or
two numbers at the extremes that
otherwise would skew the mean now the
last form of average I want to talk
about is the mode the mode has nothing
to do with icecream
the mode is literally the most frequent
number most frequent most frequent
number and in this data set it's pretty
clear what the most frequent number is I
only have one - I have three threes I
have two fours I have one 10 and if you
want to include the million I me have 1
million there so here are the number
that occurs most frequently is the 3 so
once again the mode seems like a pretty
good measure of central tendency or a
pretty good average for this data set
now the mode it's a little tricky to
deal with and you won't see it used that
often because it becomes a little
ambiguous when you know it I mean look
at this data set 2 3 4 and 5 what is the
mode there all of these numbers are
equally frequent so if you have a
situation like this then you might just
you know the mode really loses meaning
it'll might force you anyway to take the
median or the mean in some form but if
you really do have numbers that kind of
you know one shows up a lot more than
the other then the mode starts to make
sense so hopefully this has given you a
pretty good overview of how to represent
the central tendency the central
tendency of a data set very fancy word
but it's just saying look we're trying
to represent with one number all of this
data and you might say hey why do we
even worry about that only has 7 numbers
here are 8 numbers here but you can
imagine if you had several million
numbers or 7 billion numbers and you
don't want to show someone all of that
data you just want to give someone a
sense of what that numbers are on
average on average and as we said the
arithmetic mean is what I see being used
the most but in situations where you
might have
numbers that would skew the arithmetic
mean because they're so large or they're
so small the median might make a lot of
sense